hi i'm sophie turner I'm Sophie Tana
and I so feet are this is BuzzFeed quiz
quest which x-men are you let's do it
let's start which beverage is your
simpler fuel the topic kawaii what Oh
wine water kombucha soda in tea
I like tea I'm English I'm going tea I
think I might go wine I was gonna do tea
but I love me so much your room I'm
gonna go coffee picker not so super
power turning wine into water flight but
only indoors breathing fire but only in
what you do I'll burn your innards Oh
inhaling fire then rather than breathing
yeah speak fluent dinosaur mind-reading
with consent ability to forget anything
I'm going to speak fluent dinosaur for
this one I'm gonna turn wine into water
wine until what so really yeah why not I
mean you'd be such a popular person in
the party wine into water when you gonna
be better for you doing it metal around
oh yeah I've hit it now it's too late
pick a superhero catchphrase alright
alright alright let's get down to
business
love not war no and that's the tea and
yeah I know what I'm clicking that's the
team right and that's the team what are
you guys clicking you're gonna go yeah
yeah I'm going and I have you seen that
video no it was a it's this woman who is
talking oh no it's not a woman because
they bang the ball on the table so they
go she's talking my jeers and out what
they bang their ball on the table yeah
and then she's like back bang my ball on
the table Oh a drag queen oh okay she
was a Marvel sidekick
we got a spider-man Oh Black Panther
Captain Marvel for the Hulk or ant-man
I'm going black panther yeah no I might
do the Hulk I love me some Mark Ruffalo
I will go for Captain Marvel nice
another iconic squad to join the a-team
Destiny's Child the Nights Watch
Power Rangers the Scooby Gang and
Charlie's Angels
I got Destiny's Child Destiny's Child is
pretty sick actually I think I would go
Destiny's Child it was either that or
the a-team Destiny's Child
the Nights Watch you can't have sex and
just remember that right yeah but you
can in the Scooby Gang yeah Fred and
Daphne what's your number-one weakness I
watched too much Netflix I'm always late
I'm very forgetful I sleep too much I'm
too trusting
I let the little things get to me I'm
going for the little things getting to
me I'm very forgetful on the old that
one yeah I let the little things get to
me too you guys okay it's fine
everything's cool everything's fine
finally how far would you go to protect
your loved ones wouldn't put myself in
danger wouldn't put innocent lives in
danger to the ends of the earth as far
as needed and then some I'm gonna go to
the ends of the earth
I'm gonna go not that far okay I'm gonna
go as far as needed okay I got store I
got storm - what did you get yeah why
don't we read it at the same time okay
let's try that even though you didn't
start off on the good side
you found your way to the light which is
what matters in the end no one will ever
dare rain on your parade that's right
let's go I'm a wild beast I'm on the
outside you might seem scary and
intimidating it's true but on the inside
you're one of the most compassionate and
caring creatures out there you want the
best for everyone and is always there to
provide a helping hand slash poor oh I
love that oh and that's true it's true
oh this has been a great quiz anything
else on the Internet breakfast whoo
these four ways
[Music]